- Kelly.
- I have to ask you though,
50, you- did you celebrate turning 50?
That's a big, big milestone.
- Yeah, I did.
I was going back and forth of what to do
'cause I'm in Kansas City
back and forth a lot.
And so what we ended up doing
is having some friends fly in
and have some good Kansas City barbecue-
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And a weekend of lake
action and things like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I turned 50 in September, so.
- Oh, that's exciting!
- Yeah, it was great.
- I have a big one, I'm turning 40!
- You're turning? Yeah!
- I'm turning 40 and I don't-
don't know what I wanna do,
but do you ever feel like you get
a little nervous about it
'cause you feel like our
job is always around people
so maybe you don't wanna host something?
- Well, I have hosting
anxiety. I think that's-
- Me too!
- I'm a Virgo and they say-
- I'm a Taurus. But I-
- See I say, I wanna have a party,
and then I can't enjoy
myself at my own party.
- This is me!
- Yeah.
- This, and I love people.
- I do too.
- I love people.
But do you ever get, like,
a little bit of social anxiety?
'Cause there's so many people.
- [Eric] A hundred percent.
- And I'm not good at small talk.
I want like real talk.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So what I do at parties
is I just pop around.
I have bebop moments with everyone.
I try to have like, a full on moment
with everyone and just...
- But that's kind of exhausting.
- [Eric] It is.
- That's not a present on your birthday.
- I know, I agree.
- And I worry if everybody's
had enough to eat,
and enough to drink.
- Me too!
- And it does-
- It's stressful!
- It does end up being more stressful.
- Yeah.
- [Eric] It does.
- If I'm ever at a party and you're there,
I'm totally just gonna
follow you and stalk you.
- Yeah, you're just gonna
stand in the corner.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause you'll know my anxiety.
- [Eric] Yeah. Yeah, right.
- No, you'll know, you'll know.
- Um, how- you know this,
people love to give people on TV,
and maybe things, orchids.
Like, that's a popular gift.
- Yeah, it's the, the flower.
- Yeah. It's like, oh you know what?
Congratulations.
Here's an expensive flower
that will probably die in two weeks.
(Kelly laughs)
- And I'm like, every time I get an orchid
I'm committed to like-
I'm- this one's gonna live.
- Oh my gosh.
So here's the funny thing about me.
Orchids are the easiest
thing for me to keep alive.
- Ice cube?
- No, because it's just, it
takes a little bit of water.
You don't have to actually-
you can over-water it.
- Three ounces. Three ounces a week.
- Yeah. It's not that much.
It's like having a succulent.
It's awesome.
- Excuse me?
(Kelly laughs)
Kelly... I told you I'm seeing someone.
- No, succulents are so- they're so easy.
- I have a fiance.
(Eric laughs)
- I just like to put people
on and hit on them, Eric.
(Eric laughs)
- This is my new show.
- [Eric] It's great.
No it's- it is, it is a fun thing.
If you ever get flowers from
me, it will not be that basic.
I am really into flowers.
- As an orchid?
I love flowers.
Favorite flower? Gerber Daisy. Why?
Because clowns love daisies.
(voice drops dramatically)
(Kelly gasps)
- Mine? I love sunflowers.
That's when I love loyalty, adoration,
all of the meaning behind it.
- Sunflowers?
- But my favorite actually
recently is Gardenia.
You know why?
'Cause it means secret love.
- [Eric] Oh! Hello?
(Kelly gasps)
- [Eric] I told you!
- How powerful is that?
- [Eric] I love Gardenia.
- So when I send my Gardenias,
hide them from Lindsay.
I'm just kidding.
(Eric vocalizes in agreement)
- Sunflower, state flower
of the best barbecue- Kansas.
- Oh really?
- Kansas City. Yep.
- Blue Bonnett, Texas.
I'm just saying, I'm really into flowers,
and meaning of flowers.
It's crazy.
They're gonna edit all this out.
'Cause they're like, can you stop talking
about your weird obsession with flowers?
(Eric laughs)
- We'll save this for the DVD.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah. It's like go
straight to blue, right?
All right, so is it true that you
once were a security guard
at a Garth Brooks' show?
- Yeah. Well I was security
in Manhattan, Kansas,
and Garth Brooks came
to Manhattan, Kansas.
- [Kelly] You had so many jobs.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Okay.
- [Eric] Diverse, diverse.
- [Kelly] I like it. I like it.
- [Eric] Well there I am.
That's me chewing gum right there-
(Kelly laughs)
- [Eric] in front of Garth Brooks.
Garth Brooks, Mary Chapin Carpenter,
that was the tour.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Incredible. Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I actually got brought up
on stage by Mary Chapin Carpenter.
She used to do this bit in the show
where she'd, you know,
sing, serenade, one of
the security people.
Well I was the guy she brought up there,
but anyway, long story short,
I've had that picture forever.
And then when Garth was touring
and came to the forum in LA-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I made a few phone calls.
I'm like, I gotta meet Garth.
- [Kelly] He's the nicest guy!
- [Eric] He's the nicest guy-
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Eric] But I need this picture signed,
and I love what he
wrote on that other one.
So Garth, here's to circles,
full circle moments.
- [Kelly] Full circles.
- Here you are in front of me in 1995,
and now here you are in my dressing room.
- He is an incredibly thoughtful person.
- [Eric] Yeah. Very thoughtful.
(audience claps)
- He is very thoughtful. Yeah. Yeah.
That's so awesome about
Mary Chapin Carpenter,
that- did she do it on the song
with you don't have to fight,
I feel lucky tonight?
Did she do it on that song?
- No.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Now I wish I would've known.
It was a real sexy song.
- [Kelly] Okay, 'cause so is that one.
I was like, I thought she
brought a band up for that.
Anyway, we can edit that out too.
I was just curious, Eric.
- I love editing.
We're editing this as
I'm doing this right now.
TV people come to Hollywood,
and it's like you can't believe it.
(Kelly laughs)
- They talk forever.
It was so (beep) boring.